have you done any psychedelics like what
kind of cycle do mushrooms ayahuasca you
know because i
i know right now shroom psilocybin is
something i i don't i hate to say these
aren't um
i'm in a medicine tribe i come from a
medicine tribe
my mother's side of the family they
native to this land um
so you've done
psilocybin yeah
well i don't know what the shrooms
questions i grow my own mushrooms that's
amazing golden teachers golden teacher
is a good shroom strain and to be honest
with you
it's the spiritual aspect of the
mushroom you know what's crazy is i've
i've been paying attention to you the
last like few years and i'm like
i have a feeling gates is like woke in
that space i just got that feeling
yeah i just never talked about it i've
been it's such a powerful thing to like
when i see people i hate to say this
when i see people take
mushrooms and they like i take it with
candy that's processed sugar
you're not respecting the spirit of the
mushrooms the mushroom spirits like what
the beautiful thing about mushrooms
they heal what needs to be healed if a
tree is dying
under the under i'm not trying to be uh
what they call it all nerdy right no no
no this is but pachamama mother earth
the earth is our mother
she was here long before us she'll be
here long after we leave
okay
the under the ground
the roots are connected like this all of
the trees are connected if one tree over
here is the can
then what the mushrooms do is
they'll grow in a line you obviously the
mushrooms they always grow in a line
from one tree to the other
they tap down into the root system and
they bring energy from one tree to the
other
that's hot
advanced that nature is nature is more
advanced than we would ever be
that they communicate
like i know they sound weird but the
trees
they communicate with one another that's
like
if you know anything about harvesting
flowers
santa maria
like that's i hear people say weed on
like i like to address about her her
name like it's a spirit
like marijuana is a spirit santa maria
santa maria spirit
when you harvesting
you can't harvest
your flowers in the same room with the
other flowers they give off enzymes and
other flowers how do they communicate
like that
it's far more advanced than we even know
we will ever understand so
every everything has an essence and when
i say
native to this land i'm talking about
the taino indians
you know it like the taino indians is
made up of everything they made up a
choctaw cherokee everything a pet
everything because they was taken from
this land and dispersed all over the
caribbean during slavery so that's why
you got taino indians in jamaica
all the way around the caribbean to
puerto rico so that's why like i said a
taino like they
native yeah i feel like the way plants
communicate the way ants communicate i'm
just saying that because if somebody
listens they're gonna be like you said
native american you know oh you were
very
people love to critique me for some
reason
yeah i've gotten super high and just
thought how the [ __ ] do trees talk to
each other
how do ants talk to each other like
there's like a a frequency it's like an
electromagnetic pulsation
[Music]
it's electric that's why your phone
don't work around trees
that's wild that's real
uh have you ever had like a really
therapeutic
uh because you know sometimes uh for
people who don't know if you do shrooms
they got a
cert they got
certain levels of doses right there's
there's micro dosing and then there's
the hero's dose which is what people do
when they just want to like work through
30 years of [ __ ] in one sitting have you
ever had like a therapeutic moment on
shrooms i'm a big shroom guy so yes sir
yeah
was it something because i know i know a
few people who've like literally had
life-changing experiences
you've had that experience yes sir
do you remember like what it was or
because some i don't think people
understand i think people don't do it
think it's like you take shrooms and you
hallucinate or you see see things that
aren't there which it's more of like
this
it pulls back what's already there right
here's your neuropaths
it may have
the beautiful thing about the body is if
we've experienced trauma
our bodies will suppress that trauma
so we won't have to keep reliving it it
won't have to hurt us
what happens is
you may you may be exhibiting a behavior
that stems from a traumatic past
so once you sit
and really respect the mushrooms and sit
with them
and ask yourself why am i like this why
did why do i do this why do i do that
and it'll be revealed to you everything
all of the answers are within
nothing external could ever add value
have you ever done the thing
i was going to say have you ever heard
have you ever smoked the toad as mike
tyson would call it
the dmt
come on bufo i don't know what bufo is
that's the toe yeah well there's two
different way it's two different
toes
toe medicine one is bufo
that's where you smoke the when they rub
his back right that's what i'm talking
about where you freebase it and then
the other one
where you clean your lymphatic system is
combusito
combo and they take well it's to
steal the same poison but they put it on
you they burn you
and put it on your skin
that sounds great i haven't heard of
that have you done uh have you have you
tried that
like i said i i'm in a medicine trap
that's fire man i'm so scared to try it
because i hear you kind of gone for like
you know 15
yeah
like you hit it and then you're just you
just kind of i'm not saying that i ever
tried it but i'ma say you're gonna be
gone for like 10 minutes
but it's gonna feel like you've been
gone
for years
i've heard that i feel like you've been
gone for a long time but you only been
gone for 10 minutes
but
that's just those are just
starter kids like ayahuasca and excuse
me excuse me mother ayahuasca
because you got to be respectful when
you're speaking to these spirits that
they're strong as medicines that come
from the earth
but
they just start up starting kids to me
they just let you know what's already in
you
you can reach these same levels through
controlled breathing meditation
you can reach these levels
you can unlock the dmt that's naturally
produced in your body through breathing
i didn't know that yeah so all of these
feelings that we're trying to feel we
can unlock they're there
yeah there's just certain uh things that
kind of help i guess jump start yours
yeah it's like a jump start like a
starter kit it helps you understand and
realize what's already there
yeah ayahuasca is something i i know you
gotta have like a shaman and
you know probably prepare
with your diet before you do something
like that yeah it's a diet like
well that's a special diet yeah
all liquids
no food you don't want any dense energy
you want to
vibrate at the highest frequency
possible
and when you hold space you hold in a
sacred space the ceremony
um a lot of people don't talk about it i
mean i don't care to really talk about
it because when you hear about it you
hear at least yeah man it was a trip
it's not a trip like
it's not a drug
it's not something you do recreationally
right
yeah
i think that's the difference i think
like even with shrooms which is
obviously a lot more mild than ayahuasca
but
it's like you're in like when you take
it what's your intent because that's
probably what you're gonna get out of it
you gotta it's better when you do
anything you should state your
intentions you should do be intentional
with everything you do
you're drinking water
i mean water is living
i'm not trying to sound weird but it's a
spirit
it's living
life
water is life without it what are we no
you're right hey water is literally like
sound like one of those you know
eccentric people right now there's
nothing wrong with being an eccentric
guy man
i'm not trying to sound like that
what did you you kind of pulled this out
of me yeah man if it was if it was
talking about some music or some [ __ ]
then yeah but
it's like we kind of you kind of pulled
this out of me and it's just like coming
out because i usually don't have these
conversations especially in interviews
right